two employees accused of racial
profiling at a Hilton Doubletree Hotel
in Oregon or on leave this morning the
hotel apologized a second time to
Jermaine Massey in a widely shared
Instagram video and several other videos
he claimed he was targeted for quote
calling his mother while black DeMarco
Morgan shows us how this is the latest
incident of police being called on
African Americans who are doing
seemingly ordinary thang it's another
talk of this morning guys I good morning
to everyone
Jermaine Massey was returning from a
concert Saturday night when he said he
went to a quiet corner of the hotel
lobby to take a phone call from his
mother when a security officer now
dubbed hotel Earl by the internet
approached him things got heated you
really want this PR issue Errol do you
Jermaine Massey was ordered to pack his
bags and leave the Doubletree Hotel in
Portland Oregon hours after he checked
in the 71 year old security guard Earl
Wesley Myers had asked Massey force room
number Massey said he didn't remember
and requested privacy for his phone call
instead Myers called for the police why
are they coming escort you off the
property because what and I'm staying
here not anymore
even was so far to say that he's there
to protect the safety of the guests as
if I weren't a guess and I was causing a
disturbance and I was a safety threat
Massey says why guests in the lobby were
not similarly questioned you're not
worried how am i watering in an area
does public a shirt here so this area is
off-limits after a certain time only a
few I guess I am a guest I just checked
in my American Express and Vassy
produced his room key for manager he
wouldn't ask me a call
I didn't do anything to this man okay
I'm taking a phone call but responding
officers warned Massey he could be
arrested for trespassing if he stayed
yeah I need two rolls of the property
yes according to the police report the
34 year old who said he was a former FBI
agent became loud and started yelling
that the hotel was racist
you know judges someone based off the
color of their skin you never know how
it feels until you've actually been
there I could have what the jail had I
responded a different way and the past
year police have been called on a group
of black people barbecuing a girl
selling bottled water on the sidewalk
illegally selling water without a permit
and Bob Marley's granddaughter after she
and her friends left their Airbnb we're
standing here we have one two three
masts he checked into a different hotel
Saturday after he was kicked out without
a refund on Thursday the Doubletree
announced it was reviewing its protocols
and trainings and had launched an
investigation we have a zero-tolerance
stance on discrimination of any kind it
said in a statement
I plan to try to seek justice and make
sure it doesn't happen to anybody else
now Massey's attorney said in a
statement his client was publicly
humiliated and now wants the hotel to
publicly answer to two questions
why was he approached by security and
interrogated and why was he called a
threat to the safety and security of
guests and guys I got to point out this
actually happened to me about two weeks
ago at an unnamed hotel I was a security
guard who came up to me and said hey
what's your room number and I didn't it
gosh and he said it was just for
security reasons and then it was a white
couple on the side of me and thankfully
she spoke up the lady did and she said
well you didn't ask for my room number I
gave her this looked like okay for what
you know but that will take it's gonna
take us working together regardless of
your race your sex your religion
speaking out and of course are two sides
to every story so we don't know both
sides but it happens we don't know
exactly what happened here but news
flash people of color stay at hotels
they live in apartment buildings and
they go to Starbucks man they barbecue
sometimes probably Preeti DeMarco thank
you good to see you again think we're
good to see you as well